-Finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Alright. Welcome.
Welcome to "WePost."
This is where we as a group
decide something
we should post on X.
I'm going to show you
five different posts
and we're all going to vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You should at least.
If you don't, let us know.
We'll get you one.
You can vote for all of these.
You can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers?
-Got it.
-Roots, you have clickers?
-Alright. Very good.
Whatever post gets
the most likes,
we will post it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and we can "wepost" it.
It's like a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, good.
The first post is...
-Wow.
-Again, the writers have been on
strike for north of five months.
Alright. It's interesting.
A lot of people have their
phones out during the concert.
They don't watch
the show themselves.
-They just watch the thing.
-That's correct. Yeah.
So it's more of an observation
than a joke.
Sure. The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Wow.
[ Sad tuba ]
Very honest,
very honest audience.
[ Laughter ]
Very honest tonight.
Okay.
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
It's like walking on the moon.
-Uneven. They're not to code.
-I can't be the only one.
Let's see the results
right here.
Alright. A little bit better.
Not bad.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I want to remind everyone,
these don't necessarily
get better.
[ Laughter ]
That's the thing
about this game.
That might be it.
-You don't know what's coming.
-I have no idea
if it's going to get better.
I don't know if it does.
-Ready?
-Let's try this next one here.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
Just see what happens.
-Yeah.
-"Hey, enough here for two."
Maybe you can tape
a concert with your phone, yeah.
-Alright, let's see the results.
I have a good feeling
about this one. Let's see.
Oh! That's good!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just see what happens.
Why not?
Alright, let's go.
Next one up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
They're all in the bed together.
-He's faking it.
-The whole room's a bed. Right?
-Yeah.
Finds a golden ticket.
-You went yes?
-Yeah.
You go yes on all of them,
right?
-Yes, I do.
-Did you go yes
on that first one?
-Yes.
-Wow.
-I did not.
-That's interesting.
-You did not?
-No, I'm honest.
-You're honest. Yeah.
-Unless it gets in my way.
-He's honest
but he's very positive.
-Yeah.
-Did you go yes on that one?
-So, yeah, I went yes
on that one as well.
-Yeah.
-It's pretty funny.
But I think the other one
is still --
-Might be better.
-I think the other one's better.
But let's see the results.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The other one?
The other one still?
Yeah, the other one's
still in the lead.
Okay, good.
This is the last one here.
I think the other one
is going to take it.
-You think the --
-What was that one?
-184.
-No, not the --
What was the joke?
-The Uber.
-Uber.
-Oh, Uber Eats. Yeah.
Uber Eats is going to win.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah. There's no sense --
-Unless this one.
You never know.
-It's putting a lot of pressure
on this last one here.
-Well...
-I still think
it's going to be Uber.
-Okay.
-Uber Eats, but never know.
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Real.
-[ Imitating alarm blaring ]
Get out, man!
-[ Laughing ]
-Okay.
Let's see the results
on this one. Here we go.
Oh! We have a winner!
There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is Uber Eats.
"Wanna have fun,"
Uber Eats driver.
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like and enjoy.